how's it going peasants my name is pay
the pot I mean hi we're gonna play some
more fat calf oh wow yes what a lovely
day for hunting in the nature and the
wild nature of Africa
now where's my rocket launcher there it
is
all right let's do it guys
360 noscope those [ __ ] whoa fly
piggies and a pig spit out hair oh this
is how we hunt in Sweden [ __ ]
all right hey piggy hey piggy don't be
scared be gay I'm not gonna hurt you I
would never hurt you Josh
oh my god I have a problem I'll admit I
have a problem at least alright let's do
some other weapons what is this Cyprus
look at this 360 noscope kill cam got it
up oh one more flames flames away
oh that's lovely we're cookies a biga
jeanette baby
ah-ah some it happens every time I cook
every time I cook bacon I burn myself
what is that piggy trying to do piggy
thinking what I say about defying
gravity why did I say why did I say oh
god I'm a horrible person
I'm sorry I'm a [ __ ] oh I get it I have
yard and the plain wide fields of Africa
going on a regular hug this morning all
right this is gonna be great
this is how we deal with yep oh god what
is that a crocodile
are you a crocodile oh my god what are
you doing here Crockett
Oh God oh god no no for God helicopters
don't go in water
oh god I'm I am [ __ ] RJ oh god
crocodile what do you do it I killed him
I [ __ ] kill them oh my god back score
one for paired zero for Crockett dad
stupid-ass crocodile how do I get out of
here damn it
wait I could jump like a boss oh my god
what the actual [ __ ] oh god oh god a
wolf nope ah hey elephant
by elephant oh my god it's a honey
badger you know what that is coming
right for me get an extra peach oh yeah
let's get this crocodile Hey
crazies [ __ ] Craig we could be
friends krookodile we could have been
framed
oh my god it's human all right it's time
for some real hunting yeah they came
right for me there was nothing I could
do about it
it was me or them what are you doing
stop he says be dead already
hey right now what are you doing this is
my hood oh god oh god what are you doing
right Oh
crazy-ass [ __ ] now teach you who's boss
welcome to the real word 2014 [ __ ] ah
bah Hey the car is new oh god damn it if
you scratch the paint
I will kill you al-qaeda he got me he
got me he got me Oh God
how do I ride these things I'm not very
good at riding these
oh it's here RINO yeah well guess what I
have a hell-like where's this Reiner son
of a [ __ ] oh it looks like man win
again
good night you're gonna become a new
purse all right now the fun map oh my
god so many vehicles which one should I
choose
good old hovercraft now let's go to
adventure where are the enemies I don't
understand I don't understand
I see something hey guys
what's cyanate
I don't need a haircut guys I'm sorry
thank you
hi guys no no oh God
by
Oh Gary great great to see you Gary
okay I keep spinning this is just a
normal day in Sweden this is how we do
it
this is how God where did the road go
son of a dog god oh my god alright man
I'll have to ended up so there if you
enjoyed please leave a like hit
subscribe come bro today and I will see
you bros that's always thank you for
watching stay awesome